if I asked you what the largest
e-commerce company in the world was like
that most of you would answer Amazon
without even hesitating however that
might not actually be the case listen up
[Applause]
[Music]
Alibaba started 18 years ago
we'll never change our dream we believe
ecommerce we believe internet we've
believed by helping young people helping
small business and helping empower women
we will have the future
[Music]
with a market value of more than 400
billion dollars more than 600 million
customers worldwide Alibaba is an
incredible success story
it's also the most valuable Chinese
company in the world we could say that
this company has become the best
representative of the new form of
Chinese capitalism let's go back for a
second to the question that we asked at
the beginning of this video is Amazon
the largest e-commerce company in the
world well that kinda depends if for
example we take a look at the market
value that is how much investors value
the company asked then undoubtedly
Amazon is the largest company but if
instead we focus on the volume of sales
made through the company every year that
is where more goods of bought and sold
then Alibaba wins by a landslide
yes Alibaba might not be as popular or
as well known as Amazon after all it
mostly works in the Asian markets but
although it may seem far away products
worth a total of more than 750 billion
dollars are sold each year through Ali
Baba's different platforms
[Music]
now those of you who usually follow
visual politics surely won't be
surprised by what I'm saying Asia is
undergoing a revolution a take off an
unprecedented economic growth process
every year around 160 million people
leave poverty behind and manage to
become a part of the middle class 160
million people in Asia alone in the next
few years countries like the Philippines
and Thailand are going to have a middle
classes as large as those in the United
Kingdom France or Italy and then there's
China whose middle class is absolutely
exploding it's taking off almost
vertically so what happens when a person
leaves poverty behind and becomes a part
of the middle class
well the Hmong other things it means
they now have much more money to spend
this explains why the Chinese retail
market is multiplied by four in the last
five years and why forecasts indicate
that the growth Chinese consumption in
the next three to four years will be
greater than everything the British or
Germans consume today
[Music]
and do you know who holds more than 70%
of the market share in China's ecommerce
sector and is very well positioned in
the other fastest-growing Asian
countries
yep that's Alibaba through partnerships
with Alibaba Canadian producers have
been able to sell their innovative
technologies apparel and quality fresh
food to almost half a billion Chinese
customers I'm sure by now you're
beginning to see this company in a
rather different light
[Music]
but before we take a look at Ali Baba's
characteristics its light and its dark
sides let's see how it all began
let's have a look at the history
[Music]
Jack Maz miracle
he was never the best student but thanks
to the foreign tourists who visited his
hometown and especially to the
relationship he developed with an
Australian family Jack Ma a child born
in a humble family just two years before
Mao's Cultural Revolution managed to
learn English and acquired all the
advantages offered by the modern world
and as is often the case in life it
wasn't formal studies but the small
experiences the kind we often don't even
pay attention to that fed the success of
the person who is today the richest man
in all of China
I'm 100% made in China I learned English
myself I know nothing about technology
one of the reasons why Alibaba survived
is because I know nothing about
computers I'm like a blind man riding on
the back of a blind tiger Jack Ma Jack
Ma one of the heroes of the new modern
China didn't have the opportunity to
attend a good university however since
he learned English he managed to
graduate with a teaching degree got a
job as a language teacher and a few
years later launched a translation
company and he was on a trip to the
United States to perform a translation
service that some friends from Seattle
showed him what was then an incipient
technology called the Internet that
moments an idea hit Jack right in the
face I was afraid of touching the
computer because it seemed very
expensive but they said come on Jack go
ahead it's not a bomb
then I typed the word beer EEE R and I
could see German and Japanese beer but
not Chinese beer then I typed the word
China and the answer was no results then
I thought how interesting if we could
group all the companies in China and
create a page for them maybe that would
achieve something big Jack Ma and that's
precisely what he did after returning to
China Jack set up a company China pages
to list classify and thus find Chinese
companies something like the Yellow
Pages this company didn't have the
expected success but jack learns enough
to be ready for his next adventure after
a lot of work in a small apartment both
he and a team had managed to train
without virtually any resources created
Alibaba in 1999 and it's now one of the
largest companies on the planet
[Music]
the great market
more than wondering what Alibaba does we
should ask ourselves what it doesn't do
because see Alibaba isn't simply an
e-commerce portal but rather a kind of
technological intermediary in other
words unlike Amazon Alibaba doesn't sell
anything directly but basically
functions as a large market where
thousands and thousands of brands
producers and distribution companies
sell their products to millions of
customers that is Alibaba is the owner
company the company that manages this
huge market and supplies everything that
brands producers and distributors need
to be able to carry out their business
from payment platforms to metadata in
fact this may be its biggest difference
from Amazon for example think about the
huge amount of data that these companies
handle consumer trends budgets types of
customers purchase timing etc well while
Amazon uses all that data to develop its
own product lines Alibaba shares them
with the companies that operate through
their markets so that they can launch
new products or know their consumers
preferences better and thus sell more
making the market grow which makes
Alibaba grow thus over time Alibaba has
developed a several different markets so
if you'd like to better understand what
Alibaba is exactly let's take a look at
what those markets are and how they
differ first of all we have Alibaba com
the huge wholesale markets perhaps the
largest online wholesale markets on the
planet that is to say this market is an
aimed at consumers through this space
producers and manufacturers sell their
products in bulk to other companies so
they can distribute them in their
countries for example say you have a
store and you want to order 5000 red
shirts with a specific logo this is the
place that you go to unless we use
Alabama it's extremely difficult
expensive and frustrating to find a
supplier Alibaba cut out the middleman
they make it extremely easy to find
communicate and negotiate with suppliers
directly through their website Jade run
businessman and investor then in China
in addition to the local wholesale
markets which in this case is known as
1688 com Alibaba has two of the largest
retail electronic commerce markets in
the country Taobao and Timur
see Taobao is pretty much a combination
between Amazon and eBay here practically
anyone can sell their products it's a
market with thousands and thousands of
suppliers and almost 600 million active
consumers team all on the other hand is
a large online shopping center oriented
towards big brands here the brand's pay
a fee to have their own store basically
like any shopping mall then one of the
lesser-known crown jewels
Alibaba owns more than 80% of Lozada the
most important ecommerce company in
South Asia this is a company that
operates in countries like Indonesia
Vietnam Malaysia Singapore and Thailand
and watch out because we aren't talking
about something small-scale only in the
next two to three years these countries
will see their middle class multiplied
by two to surpass 400 million people 400
million people that Alibaba wants to
turn into customers and finally we have
what is probably the best known platform
for most of us Aliexpress an
international consumer oriented platform
well these folks are Ali Baba's main
markets but the company's activities
don't end there
[Music]
Alibaba is also one of the five most
important powered computing companies in
the world and of course it's China's
undisputed leader and this divisions
growth rate has surpassed a hundred
percent annually in recent years
companies such as KPMG Nestle Philips
and sa P already use a li cloud services
it also owns UQ a streaming platform
similar to YouTube led China's largest
home delivery company which among many
other companies also holds a significant
share of why though something like the
Chinese Facebook but just a second have
any of you heard of Ali pay for those
who don't know what it is Ali pay is
very similar to PayPal it has more than
870 million active users and is the
leader in the Chinese mobile payment
market because see in China credit cards
aren't common at all
the Chinese have jumped directly to
mobile payments so when they go to the
supermarket instead of paying with visa
or mastercard they use Ali pay or we
chats payment services the two main
payment systems in the Chinese market
while Alibaba owns 33% of Anne's
financial the company that owns Ali pay
and also paid him the leading mobile
payment application in India and other
strongly growing markets to give you an
idea of what this means and financials
estimated value surpasses a hundred and
fifty billion dollars but just a moment
because if this entire online bet wasn't
enough Alibaba is also investing
billions in supermarkets and other
physical stores where it has its own
brand Hema and is also the largest
shareholder in the Sun art retail group
the largest supermarket and hyper market
operator in all of China
so as you can see the Alibaba Empire
extends its tentacles into a lot of
sectors to sum things up Alibaba has
services equivalent to those of Amazon
eBay just eat Visa YouTube Facebook and
even Carrefour all in the same company
certainly not bad well this is precisely
why this company is worth more than four
hundred billion dollars on the stock
market but I don't think we can end this
story without talking about the future
risks and opportunities
however we look at it alibaba's plans
very ambitious
by 2020 sales made through alibaba's
different platforms will exceed 1
trillion dollars
[Music]
and in just 18 years the company aims to
surpass 2 billion customers
[Music]
so yeah that's the gold but will they
achieve it well obviously we can't know
but the truth is that it has many cards
on the table see
despite this company's huge growth since
its foundation in 1999 it still has
great potential
not only because ecommerce is growing a
lot around the worlds but also because
everything indicates that growth will be
explosive for many years particularly in
this region let's take a look at for
example of China Ali Baba's main market
here the Internet has only expanded by
55% so there's still a lot of work to do
we're talking about hundreds of millions
of people who will sooner or later
connect to the internet and start making
their first online purchases and not
only that given that Chinese purchasing
power is growing stronger year after
year the same is happening with the
average amount of purchases seats in
2015 the average Alibaba customers
spending has grown by 50% in China so if
we combine more spending and more
clients well you can see how enormous
the potential is here and then in
addition there are the countries which
belong to the Association of Southeast
Asian Nations and also India we're
talking about an area of the world that
is not only gonna see huge economic
growth but is also estimated to grow by
more than 700 million people in the next
three decades all of this is of course
in addition to the international market
now hold on a sec because everything's
not so rosy like many Internet companies
who focus all their attention on growing
and growing the company isn't actually
making much money
[Music]
in this case we're talking about a four
hundred billion dollar company that has
barely managed to make a net profit of
eight point four billion dollars in the
last 12 months and that might sound like
a lot of money but the market value is
50 times a net profit and that's a lot
and of course one might think well okay
okay but so what I mean it's definitely
gonna make money in the future
well maybe or you know maybe not because
if the market grows so much it usually
entails a very strong incentives for new
competitors new rivals something that is
already happening in a certain way look
competitors like JD comm and especially
pin duo duo are investing a lot of money
to compete with Alibaba and even though
they are very successful they may never
beat Alibaba or maybe they will the
truth is that no matter what it adds
more pressure to the market which may
reduce the margins in which these
companies operate in the future and then
of course is that Chinese government
which as you know is not exactly the
best guarantor in the world as you know
the Chinese government doesn't unders
and they can even determine who survives
in a market and who doesn't that means
that a botched delivery to a communist
party leader could become Ali Baba's
worst nightmare
[Music]
in any case it's clear that Alibaba is
the best example of the changes that our
world is experiencing how Asia is
gaining power and how it's beginning to
acquire its own large multinationals and
it's something we're gonna have to get
used to so I really hope you enjoyed
this video please do hit that like
button if you did and don't forget to
subscribe for brand new videos also
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider Media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine also this channel this
video it's all possible because of
patreon and our patrons on that platform
please do consider joining them and
supporting us in our mission of
providing independent political coverage
and as always I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]